one of the traps of modern humans is
just living a materialistic life and
just chasing [__] non-stop for what why
the [__] doesn't matter like we just
Chase bigger and bigger boxes to live in
faster and faster cars all this stuff
but like why why not just skip all that
and just do fun [__] like make content
or build a business or things like that
everyone dies with nothing whatever you
accumulate doesn't come with you it
sounds so simple but like we don't live
our life in that way even the idea that
we're going to pass it on to Generations
but if you multiply out Generations 20
times over then the people aren't even
really related to you they're just other
humans and so winning the game of life
is playing the game of life